winter is coming and the struggle for
the Iron Throne is not over yet
breaker of chains let's start right off
the King's Landing
things have been completely reconfigured
in the wake of what happened at the end
of the last episode which I still can't
talk about kind of keeping things
spoiler free Tyrion is now in jail which
I don't consider to be a spoiler because
the previews for the season show that he
was in jail I figure that's fair game
and I like seeing him in jail I don't
mean that in a way like I wanted to see
him arrested beaten down further or
anything like that I just mean like back
him into a corner and he's more
interesting Tyrion is at his best when
he has something that he can confront
head-on
obviously not physically he's not a
fighter but that he can get out with his
wit and his words and his just find a
way to work his way around it and a
trial definitely seems like something
that'll go that way Tywin master
manipulator that he is has a really
interesting scene with Oberyn to see the
two of them start to do the little kind
of dance around each other you know
trying to figure out what they can get
from the other one and still get what
they want it's really interesting it's
always interesting no matter how many
times I see it Sansa I'm still hesitant
to say that she herself has become
interesting but the character is being
put in increasingly interesting
situations so there's still potential
that I may eventually even like her
Petyr Baelish has come back and the
minute I saw him show up I just thought
oh [ __ ] his monologue that he had in the
last episode he appeared in last season
just really let everybody know this guy
is out for himself way worse than you
ever thought and he does not care who
goes down so him coming back honestly
kind of scary a little bit there's a
scene between Jamie and Cersei that I
I'm not sure how I feel about it's it's
a very sexually charged scene which is
fitting for them they've got that
history and all that but just the way it
plays out I'm not sure how I feel about
it and it actually leads me to another
sort of talking point I want to bring up
I hesitate to call this show
misogynistic but it's a hard label
to avoid when the society that is
showing is inherently misogynistic but I
just feel like we're kind of getting
beaten over the head with this and it
just seems like every single female
character in this show has either
endured or been threatened with sexual
violence and it's really starting to
make me uncomfortable as a viewer I mean
I understand that's the world that they
live in but I think we're beyond just
making the point right now between what
goes on with Searcy and Jamie and then
Samwell has Gilly leave Castle black
because he's afraid of what the members
of the Night Watch will do to her and
like that sort of thing just permeates
the whole show and it's always been
there I'm just sort of starting to think
issue with it more it's actually gotten
worse I feel like it's gotten worse
maybe it's just that it's been watching
it so long that it's just starting to
wear on me I'm going yet that's kind of
enough since I brought up Sam on Gilly
let's take a look at what's going on
north of the wall we get a really
important bit of insight into the
wildlings and I don't mean in terms of
some great depth to me I mean we see
firmly viscerally why these guys are a
problem because we've you know we've
seen the wildlings gathering and we've
been told oh they're gonna march on the
wall and take everybody out we've been
told that but it's all been fairly
abstract and one of the point there was
always something in the background head
that went well they don't like the White
Walkers nobody likes the White Walkers
aren't we they just ultimately all gonna
join up and fight the White Walkers well
it becomes fairly clear now why that's
never gonna work we get a little more
time with Arya and the Hound and it's
interesting just watching Arya developed
obviously she's you know she's been
dealing with death quite a bit and even
in some cases death at her own hands
but she still I don't want to say naive
she's still got a certain sense of
nobility a certain code of ethics and
honor going to her more so than the
Hound so for her to see this this night
who is able to justify doing much worse
things than she is willing to do it's
interesting I'm gonna be interested to
see how that impacts her development
overall but the title of the episode
deals of course with Daenerys Targaryen
who can do
used to sweep her way across slavers Bay
taking out every single slave city she
comes across freeing all the slaves and
just amassing her forces as much as
she's got a fairly impressive army at
her command at this point her real
strength really seems to be in what she
is able to inspire in others and get
them to rally to her she is the
character that I was waiting to get to
see when I first became clear where her
direction was way back in season one now
she's this is it this is her breaker of
chains mother of dragons yeah this
season as a whole is just really strong
right out the gate and it's maintaining
momentum very well I mean yeah I've got
the thing with the sexual violence which
I'm a little bit uh bugged by at this
point but just this whole show and story
and characters I'm just I'm wrapped up
in it and not too many of my issues from
last season are lingering or at least if
they're popping up they're popping up
briefly and they're going away again so
I'm really excited for the next episode
let me ask you this because opinions
seem to vary
do you still dig the nudity and the
sexual aspects of the show or do you
feel like it's gimmicky at this point
whatever you think leave something down
in the comments let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned